die nachrichten des tages
heute mit niedrigen löhnen guten abend
ihnen allen kristin otto sie dabei mehr
und heute abend da wird es spannend für
die deutsche
fußball-nationalspieler nicht einfach
guten abend wir schauen uns jetzt
gemeinsam den überblick
die zahl der hungernden menschen auf der
welt steigt mehr als 800 millionen haben
nicht genug zu essen
tauschverhältnis eins zu eins nach
monaten im sinkflug war der euro heute
nur noch einen dollar wert
fotos von milliarden jahre alten
galaxien das weltraumteleskop james webb
ermöglicht einen blick zu den anfängen
des universums
[Musik]
den hunger auf der erde bis 2030 zu
beseitigen dieses ziel hatten sich die
vereinten nationen gesetzt und man muss
leider sagen dieses ziel rückt in weite
ferne dürren corona pandemie krieg und
die folgen haben die globale
ernährungssituation nachhaltig
verschlechtert der welthungerhilfe
bericht 2021 fasst diese entwicklung in
erschreckende zahl weltweit leiden etwa
828 millionen menschen hunger und die
lebensmittelpreise verschärfen die
situation und die waren schon
2021 also vor dem krieg in der ukraine
weltweit um 28 prozent gestiegen
besonders dramatisch ist die situation
am horn von afrika durch die schlimmste
dürre seit 40 jahren droht allein dort
17 millionen menschen der hungertod aus
somalia berichtet sandra theis
90 kilometer weit ist oblio hassan salat
gelaufen aus ihrem dorf bis in somalias
hauptstadt mogadischu hier in einem
zentrum gegen unterernährung bekam sie
endlich hilfe
ich hatte zwölf kinder vier davon sind
durch die dürre gestorben von den acht
die überlebt haben musste ich vier
zurück lassen sie sind krank diesem hier
ging es am schlechtesten deshalb habe
ich es mit genommen um es zu retten der
hunger trifft die schwächsten am
härtesten vor allem die kinder schon
eine durchfallerkrankung kann den tod
bedeuten
hilfsorganisationen warnen vor einem
massensterben am horn von afrika
millionen kinder sind schwer
mangelernährt hunderttausende kinder in
somalia
sind von akuten hungertod bedroht wenn
ihnen nicht in den nächsten wochen und
monaten geholfen werden kann grund ist
die schwerste dürre seit jahrzehnten
hinzu kommt der krieg in der ukraine
somalia bezog mehr als 90 prozent seines
weizens aus der ukraine und russland
doch die lieferwege sind blockiert die
preise für lebensmittel in die höhe
geschossen das bekommen noch
hilfsorganisationen zu spüren es fehlen
die mittel die meisten spenden flossen
in die ukraine während am horn von
afrika millionen menschen hunger leiden
wenn die welt nicht aufhört nur auf die
ukraine zu schauen und nicht sofort
handelt wird das kinder sterben am horn
von afrika explosionsartig zunehmen es
ist ein wettlauf gegen die zeit und mit
jedem tag wird die lage schlimmer
diese menschen brauchen hilfe so wäre
unterstützung möglich über dieses
spendenkonto beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe die bahn de 65 104 106
100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf hunger in
afrika
mehr infos auch unter spenden punkt
zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite
jetzt in den süden der ukraine dort hat
die armee nach eigenen angaben eine
gegenoffensive gestartet und zwar im
gebiet von persson dass russen derzeit
besetzt halten in der stadt nova chaos
gab es in der nacht mehrere explosionen
nach darstellung des ukrainischen
militärs brannte dort ein waffendepot
die staatliche russische
nachrichtenagentur tass sprach dagegen
von treffern in einem lager für
mineraldünger dabei seien mindestens
sieben menschen getötet und mehr als 70
verletzt worden
wer bekommt bevorzugt gas sollte es noch
knapper werden galt laut notfallplan
bislang das private haushalte oder
kritische infrastruktur den vorrang vor
der energieintensiven industrie bekommen
aber genau das zweifelt
wirtschaftsminister habeck jetzt an die
details hat patricia wiedemeier die
stadt nürnberg will in der krise ein
zeichen setzen und schließt deshalb im
sommer ein großteil ihrer hallenbäder
diese seien sehr energieintensiv jetzt
sparen sei ein beitrag um für volle
energie speicher im winter vorzusorgen
das bedeutet auch einige einschränkungen
und das heißt einschränkungen für die
vereine einschränkungen jetzt auch noch
während der schulzeit für die schulen
aber auch für die öffentlichkeit
verschlossene hallenbäder gedrosselte
heizungen viele vorschläge um gas zu
sparen sollte es tatsächlich knapp
werden dann jedoch so sieht es derzeit
eine eu verordnung vor würde zuletzt bei
privaten haushalten rationiert doch
genau dieses prinzip stellt nun
wirtschaftsminister habeck in frage
niemand soll frieren aber das private
haushalte auch ihren anteil leisten und
dass eine dauerhaft oder langfristige
unterbrechung von industrieller
produktion massive folgen auch für die
gesamtwirtschaft hat für die menschen im
land fehlt die versorgungssituation das
denke ich es inzwischen auch erkannt
auch der deutsche industrie- und
handelstag fordert dass alle private
haushalte und unternehmen ihren beitrag
leisten wenn es wirklich zur abschaltung
und kommt dann bedeutet das ja für die
unternehmen dass sie faktisch
geschlossen werden dass sie nicht
produzieren können dann kommen wir
wieder zur situation dass die kurzarbeit
zunimmt und die unternehmen aber weiter
fixkosten haben ohne industrie gehen am
ende tatsächlich im wasser die lichter
aus nächste woche will die eu ihre
strategie zur
energieversorgungssicherheit vorstellen
wer dann im falle des diese zuerst
berücksichtigt wird diese diskussion
wird sicherlich noch an schärfe zunehmen
sie haben das sicher mitbekommen schon
länger ist der euro unter druck gründe
gibt es viele aktuell den ukraine krieg
und die drohende rezession
heute ergab der sinkflug diese
schlagzeile ein euro ist nur noch genau
einen dollar wert und das gab es zuletzt
vor 20 jahren kurz nach der bargeld
einführung der europäischen
gemeinschaftswährung
danach stieg der euro 2008 dann sogar
auf über einen dollar 60 aber seit
januar 2021 da geht die kurve fast nur
noch nach unten bis heute bis zum
gleichstand wir wollen nachfragen bei
frank widmann in frankfurt an der börse
frank es gibt nach 20 jahren quasi
wieder einen euro dollar gleichstand
welche rolle spielt da der dollar und
was bedeutet diese parität jetzt
tatsächlich die jetzige euro schwäche
hat auch viel mit der dollarstärke zu
tun das sieht man allein daran dass der
us-dollar auch gegenüber anderen
währungen deutlich zulegt warum in den
usa gibt es mehr zinsen für das geld ein
stärkeres wirtschaftswachstum und vor
allem eine inflationsbekämpfung ohne
wenn und aber
dazu kommt die durch krieg und die
gaskrise hausgemachte schwäche des euros
das tief jetzt kommt zur unzeit weil es
die inflation weiter anfacht und das
hängt viel mit dem einkauf von
rohstoffen auf den weltmärkten zusammen
rohstoffe wie öl oder gas werden in
dollar abgerechnet und das heißt für
energie und andere güter müssen die
deutschen importeure künftig mehr euro
für die gleiche dollar rechnung zahlen
eine verteuerung die sich allein aus dem
ungünstigen euro wechselkurse gibt und
die die importeure davon ist auszugehen
dann auch an die endverbraucher
weitergeben werden danke schön euer
frankfurt frank bethmann
ja und der euro sorgt heute noch für
eine weitere schlagzeile kroatien kann
zum ersten januar 2023 die
gemeinschaftswährung einführen die
eu-finanzminister macht den weg dafür
frei mit kroatien gehören ab dem
jahreswechsel dann 20 eu länder der
eurozone an die erwartungen im land sind
recht unterschiedlich wie britta hilpert
und er zeigt
so sieht den kroatien ein wachstumsmotor
aus vor allem tourismus machte die
wirtschaft hier fit für den euro brüssel
gibt heute grünes licht für den euro in
kroatien im tourismus haben sie das
praktisch vorweggenommen
working wir arbeiten schon lange mit dem
preis alle unsere preise sind bereits in
euro ausgezeichnet explain den us-
dennoch es ist ein schlechter zeitpunkt
für die euro-einführung wegen der
energiekrise steigen auf dem markt die
preise die kroaten befürchten dass der
euro das verstärkt
ich erwarte eine hohe inflation von 10%
nichts gutes von uns
wir haben angst alles wird teurer aber
für den euro spricht dass wir näher an
europa kommen in der eu ist kroatien bei
der wirtschaftsleistung nur auf platz 21
die eu wird es kaum merken wenn die
cooler geht und der euro kommt kroatiens
handel aber hat davon vorteile meint man
in der außenhandelskammer
profitieren werden mit sicherheit import
und export unternehmen mit sicherheit
eher aufgrund aufgrund eben diese
einfachheit der bezahlung weg weiter
risiken ab ersten januar wird in
kroatiens kassen also der euro klingen
es wird den urlaub dort vielleicht nicht
billiger aber einfacher machen
der eur welt oder krisenwährung wie sich
die aktuelle situation in europa auf die
gemeinschaftswährung aus wirkt das alles
können sie nochmal nachlesen in der zdf-
heute- app
nicht erst seit dem russischen einmarsch
in die ukraine ist klar krieg findet
auch digital statt staatlich
orchestrierten hacker angriffe aus china
oder eben russland können enorme schäden
anrichten um sich stärker gegen cyber
angriffe zu schützen schlägt in den
ministerin feser eine
grundgesetzänderung vor damit
cybersicherheit in zukunft nicht mehr
auf länder sondern eben bundesebene
organisiert wird 1 leiten von las
bohnsack
cyber angriffe nehmen stetig zu die
stadt witten im letzten oktober
sämtliche programme der verwaltung von
unbekannten lahmgelegt einer von
tausenden hacks jährlich bei denen
bislang verschiedene landesbehörden
zuständig und häufig überfordert waren
künftig soll das bundesamt für
sicherheit in der informationstechnik
bsi übernehmen es reicht nicht dass das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik den ländern
amtshilfe leistet wir werden deshalb
eine grundgesetzänderung
vorschlagen um das bsi zu einer
zentralstelle im bund länder verhältnis
auszubauen von der opposition kommt der
vorwurf dass seit jahren viel zu wenig
in die cyber sicherheit investiert
worden wäre auch und gerade auf
bundesebene vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium weiß ich
daher dass es seit über einem jahr dort
80 prozent der it sicherheits stellen
nicht besetzt sind die netze des bundes
die hardware sind auch in einem sehr
schlechten zustand künftig will der
boden zur gefahren abwehr auf fremde
server zugreifen können die für einen
angriff genutzt werden präventive
gegenschläge auch hacks genannt sollen
ausgeschlossen bleiben ein hack beck ist
ein aggressiver gegenschlag das heißt
wie würden mit staatlichen mitteln einen
anderen server ein möglicherweise
ausländischen aktiv bekämpfen und gegen
schlagen das will niemand noch hat es
seit beginn des ukraine kriegs laut
innenministerium keinen direkten
russischen cyber angriff auf deutsche
rechner gegeben aber auch darauf will
die bundesregierung mit ihrer neuen
strategie vorbereitet sein
das haben sie noch nie gesehen die nasa
hat heute dieses foto veröffentlicht
dass unsere vorstellungskraft fast
sprengt es ist ein blick ins frühe
universum vor mehr als 13 milliarden
jahren in die zeit der ersten sterne und
planeten aufgenommen hat es das james
webb weltraumteleskop und mit hilfe
dieses sechseinhalb meter großen
hauptspiegels kann es tiefer ins all
blicken als alle seine vorgänger und
dabei spielt das lichtspektrum eine
besondere rolle weil das hightech
teleskop einen großteil der
infrarotstrahlung erkennt so kann es
weltraum nebel durchdringend und bislang
unbekannte galaxien erforschen
wer jetzt von lincoln klinge
es hat fast etwas historisches der
amerikanische präsident präsentiert das
erste bild des weltraumteleskops james
webb es ist der vollständigste und
scherzte blick tief in die vergangenheit
des universums den es je gab bis kurz
nach dem urknall
es ist ein neues fenster in die
geschichte unseres universums und heute
erhaschen wir einen blick auf das erste
licht das durch dieses fenster scheint
das ausnahme teleskop ist nach rund 30
jahren entwicklungszeit vor sechs
monaten ins all gestartet eine
gemeinsame mission von nasa esa und der
kanadischen weltraumbehörde und nun die
feierliche vorstellung der ersten bilder
in amerika und europa eine solch
detaillierte ansicht der geburtsstätte
von sternen im nebel zum beispiel ist
neu
erste daten eines exoplaneten der also
außerhalb unseres sonnensystems liegt
deuten gar auf anzeichen von wasser hin
eine der grundlagen für mögliches leben
so etwas wie das webprojekt gibt es
höchstens einmal pro generation
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern das ist tatsächlich so
was wie die mondlandung für die
astrophysik das ist so
empfindlich teleskop das wir werden neue
sachen finden dass wir haben keine
träume davon gehabt james webb ist der
nachfolger des weltraumteleskops hubble
und soll 10 bis 20 jahre im all bleiben
diese aufnahmen sind erst der anfang
wer schon einmal mit einem pedelec also
landläufig mit einem e-bike einen berg
hochgefahren ist weiß daran kann man
sich gewöhnen
und die können auch richtig schnell
werden und im straßenverkehr dann
entsprechend gefährlich zu unfällen mit
e-bikes gibt es jetzt erstmals eine
bundesweite statistik über die
ergebnisse isabel de la vega
fahrräder pedelecs e roller immer mehr
verkehrsteilnehmer müssen sich die
straße mit den autos teilen während die
zahl der unfälle mit fahrrädern gesunken
ist steigt sie bei den pedelecs weiter
an im jahr 2014 hatten 2200 menschen mit
dem pedelec einen unfall im vergangenen
jahr waren es 17 1045 bei den tödlich
verunglückten stieg die zahl von 39 auf
131 ein grund es gibt immer mehr
pedelecs inzwischen schon über sieben
millionen pedelecs sind elektrofahrräder
die maximal 25 kilometer pro stunde
fahren dürfen das tempo wird
unterschätzt wir sehen im
unfallgeschehen im unterschied zum
fahrrad eben sehr viele stürze also
unfälle ohne einen weiteren beteiligten
und das liegt eben daran dass man dort
erstens relativ schnell unterwegs ist
und zweitens das fahrzeug natürlich
ziemlich schwer ist von schweren
unfällen sind vor allem senioren
betroffen knochenbrüche und gefährliche
kopfverletzungen unfallchirurgen führen
dass auch auf eine sinkende
reaktionsfähigkeit im alter zurück sie
sind natürlich mit ihrem alltag
zunehmend so dass sie eine gewisse
verlangsamung einfach erleben und das
ist etwas was in hand immer schneller
werdenden unübersichtlichen
straßenverkehr eigentlich genau
kontraproduktiv ist experten raten daher
dringend zum helm und empfehlen pedelec
kurse
er war gleichzeitig historiker und
journalist mit einem faible für
frankreich johannes willms ist im alter
von 74 jahren gestorben zdf zuschauer
kennen ihn vor allem als moderator der
kultursendung aspekte die er ab ende der
80er jahre moderierte nebenbei erfährt
er damals auch das literarische quartett
über bücher streiten laut schaaf aber
immer mit witz dieses konzept hatte er
sich mit marcel reich ranicki gemeinsam
ausgedacht auch seine eigenen bücher
etwa über paris oder napoleon legte er
so an komplexe stoffe ja aber unbedingt
unterhaltsam und griffig
so zweites em spiel für die
fußballerinnen gegen spanien das wird
spannend christi sollte wirklich alles
passen mit einem sieg gegen spanien
würde das viertelfinale ganz nahe rücken
doch nach dem ausfall von lehrer schüler
wegen corona und den muskulären
problemen von lina magull wird die
startelf anders aussehen als beim
überragenden 14 0 gegen dänemark hat der
straße am stadion in brand was weißt du
schon von den plänen der bundestrainerin
also die gute nachricht vorneweg lina
magull kann und wird heute abend spielen
die medizinische abteilung des dfb hat
die schmerzen im oberschenkel in den
griff bekommen und sie ist ja so immens
wichtig für das deutsche team mit ihrem
10 hat sie diesen 40 torreigen gegen
dänemark am freitag eröffnet und sie
wurde vollkommen zu recht auf spielerin
des spiels und die zweite nachricht ganz
aktuell aus diesem abend für die
anwohner erkrankte lehrer schüler wird
alexandra popp in die startelf rücken
die frau mit den aktuellen meisten
länderspielen also die erfahrenste und
sie soll in der spanischen defensive für
ordentlich unruhe sorgen es wird ein
packendes spiel hier in der sogenannten
hammer gruppe b 21 uhr geht's los
deutscher zeit in bradford deutschland
gegen spanien wir freuen uns vielen dank
katja zu dir nach london die deutsche
hockey spielerinnen haben bei der
weltmeisterschaft das halbfinale
erreicht nach dem mühsamen erfolg gegen
südafrika steigerte sich das team in
amsterdam und setzte sich gegen die
zuvor ungeschlagenen frauen aus
neuseeland durch den treffer von lena
michael erneut mit 1 0 durch
gerade mal um elf sekunden hat lennart
kenner das gelbe trikot bei der tour de
france verpasst auf der zehnten etappe
kam als zehnter ins ziel sein vorsprung
auf spitzenreiter tg bogacz aarau
slowenien reicht aber für platz zwei in
der gesamtwertung tagessieger ganz knapp
der däne magnus court niesen
das verhältnis ist längst zerrüttet ein
neuer vertrag über drei jahre beim fc
barcelona liegt angeblich vor gleichwohl
erschienen stürmerstar robert
lewandowski am vormittag pflichtbewusst
und pünktlich zum obligatorischen
medizincheck der bayern in einem
münchner krankenhaus bezweifelt wird
allerdings dass er auch am samstag zur
mannschaftspräsentation im stadion noch
dabei sein wird wahrlich kein ende was
ein theater allerdings frage schön
christin morgen im norden mäßig warm im
südwesten dagegen sommerlich heiß mehr
wetter dann gleich von katja horneffer
des heute journal mit marietta slomka um
21 uhr 40 morgen an dieser stelle
barbara hahlweg von uns schönen dank für
sie einen schönen abend
[Musik]
guten abend das hoch josef bringt morgen
schon dem westen und südwesten
deutschlands hohe temperaturen dass die
barbara dagegen bringt einige wolken mit
und unter so einem tief bleibt es ja
deutlich kühler das macht sich besonders
bei dem tief selber bemerkbar dort
liegen morgen die höchsttemperaturen
nämlich nur bei 17 grad im süden
spaniens sind es dagegen schwer
erträgliche 45 grad große unterschiede
sind das und die gibt es auch bei
unseren nachttemperaturen am niederrhein
sinken die werte nicht unter 19 grad am
alpenrand sind es dagegen neun grad dort
ist der himmel klar sonst gibt es viele
wolken und auch morgen ziehen über
norddeutschland viele wolken hinweg und
es ist nicht völlig ausgeschlossen dass
da auch mal ein spritzer regen fällt in
süddeutschland bleibt es dagegen trocken
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen an
der küste bei 22 bis 24 grad sonst
werden 28 bis 31 grad erreicht und im
südwesten sind es 33 bis 34 grad am
donnerstag wird es mit 36 grad im
südwesten sogar noch heißer es gibt
einzelne gewitter richtung thüringer
wald oberpfälzer und bayerischer wald
und einzelne regenschauer in
norddeutschland freitag und samstag
bringen dann eher ruhiges sommer wird
damit wenig regenschauern und etwas
kühleren temperaturen guten abend